as I go through this I will step through
it nice and gently and please stop me at
any point we like went too fast okay now
just eyes up for a minute
pin out of hand because I want to point
out something with tree things actually
the first thing is just to have a look
back at our original graph I should have
mentioned this earlier what is that new
blue graph what does it look like looks
like a cubic which is exactly what we
should expect because you've got an an X
or some kind times an x squared of some
other kinds you light X cubed right
you're like cool at least I've got the
rough shape sometimes you'll start
plotting some points and you make some
numerical error by mistake and then
you'll be like wait a second this thing
looks crazy okay you can use a very very
rough sense check to know you've got an
overall shape now the second thing is
when you look at this you may I would
completely understand to be honest this
is my reaction I would completely
understand if you looked at this and
said sir bit overkill right like how
many lines you want to put them is now
there is a very I hope very good reason
why I put so many lines on and I'm going
to try and justify that for you right
now on this graph I put in that y equals
1 and that y equals negative 1 that
we've done in the past because it's one
of those sets of important values that
ends up being very useful I'm gonna go
all the way from left to right ok so
let's start over on this side see how
this y equals negative 1 is one of the
graphs see that so I've got negative 1
times some other value right when you
take some other value multiply it by
negative 1 what do you get negative of
that other value now what does it look
like to you roughly looks like roughly 5
5 and a half you could use a ruler you
know to actually get that there in fact
I'm just gonna check that now that looks
to me like it's just slightly about 5 ok
so therefore when I multiply that by
negative 1 I should be down here just
slightly
I guess below negative 5 yeah so I'm
gonna go ahead and then great thing
about these vertical lines is they give
you the place where that cross is going
to go right it's going to sit on that
vertical line so I'm going to go ahead
and put a cross there and now I'm moving
from left to right ok have a look here
I've got this vertical line matches to
where this guy is 1 right so one of the
graphs is 1 when you multiply 1 by some
R the number which is here you get the
other number right 1 times this which I
don't even know
what it is and I don't care I'm just one
times that is that so I'm gonna put a
little cross in there what's my next one
over
what next vertical line you see what's
happening here one of the one of the
ordinates
the both ordinate our eyes ero when X is
negative 2 right so I've got oh yeah I
still got my crosses there we go
is it cross there and I'm just gonna
keep on going right what's happening
here negative 1 times this thing will be
negative of that thing now this you
ought to be careful I call that distance
there I'm just gonna go down lower okay
so that returns right it's just like
sort of wiggled around right well that's
the shape we're getting I moved over
what am I getting here 1 times that
looks like negative 3 doesn't it should
be negative 3 you see you starting to
get the hang of it and how you don't
actually need to know what the numbers
are you just need to know where they are
on the graph okay it is like a snake
exactly right now I've cheated slightly
here but you can actually do this on
your page if you want when I look over
to my next vertical line the next
vertical line was supplied to me as the
y-axis but you're like you've got 2 and
negative 4 which jerks it's not on the
original graph they were supplied right
so I've just gone ahead and I've gone a
bit further 2 times negative 4 is
negative 8 right yeah you can go as far
as you like right you got plenty space
on the page but do please notice my
scale is consistent that's vital right
scale is actually something very
important here ok I'm on the homestretch
now I will do this a bit faster so
you've got negative 1 times about 4
which is about negative 4 what's my next
one over my second last vertical line
second last photo call it yeah the
ordinate is 0 so I'm going to go through
0 and then the last one is 1 times
whatever is up there which is whatever
is up there ok so now I've got a whole
bunch of blue dots okay now before I
connect the dots I just want to do one
more thing do you remember when we were
looking at printing function together we
often paid attention to the sign of
those graphs right positive or negative
and I'm going to do that again for this
it's gonna be really helpful okay
for example just eyes up for me for
saying have a look from here to the left
right from here to the left you notice
the parabola is positive and it's always
positive in this little area and the
street light is negative it's always
negative to the left of this intercept
right so can you tell me
irrespective of the size of these values
if you take a positive number times a
negative number
what will the sign be it'll be negative
it must be negative so my new graph my
product graph and I'd love if you've got
a highlight or whatever is gonna be
negative in this area to the left of
that intercept I'm just gonna color that
in nice and carefully like so positive
times negative is negative good morning
let's let's keep on going what about
here what about in between here and here
you've got a this straight line what's
the sine the straight line is I'm
looking at the ordinates right the Y
values these guys are above so that's
positive right it's again positive times
what's down here it's negative
isn't it so I'm gonna keep on shading in
this negative space down here
right which is consistent with all of
those crosses that I drew before right
Judas that and then the last thing is
have a look to the right over here the
parabola is now positive and also the
straight line is positive irrespective
of their size if you multiply two
positive numbers together what would
their sign be positive so lastly I'm
gonna shade up here so you can see our
new graph is going to go all the way
through these regions all the way
through those crosses what do you reckon
you go shape it's gonna be interesting
okay so I'm gonna go slip down whoop all
the way down here I'm gonna do the left
part as well like that this is gonna be
super steep isn't it really really steep
really steep steeper than I thought it
was before there we go
this needs some work but you've got the
general shape there and now I'm going to
go clean through it with a single line
what do you think does it match yours
you happy with that does again does this
match what we sort of expect what kind
of graph is this new one what does it
look like to you looks like a cubic
because again I was doing a parabola
times a straight line okay now just a
couple of quick notes before we leave
off please know because it is a cubic
like these are smooth graphs so you can
see here what are these shapes called
again starts with an S
these are stationary points so these
can't be sharp they can't be like pointy
even though it's quite hard to graph
you've got to make sure you have like a
smooth part here as all cubics do and
then yes it is hard to do this plot it's
always almost like straight up but
you've got to make sure you hit those
points that you marked in before okay